hello everyone and welcome back to the
road to 2000 as always my name is caleb
demby
and tonight i want to take you through
some exciting games
from the super bet chess classic going
on right now
in romania so there were a lot of
interesting games
i want to go over two from today and if
we have time
i want to go over one from round two as
well so we've got a lot to get through
tonight i just want to jump right into
it here
so let's jump on over to uh
the show here oh and it's actually
looking a little bit jumpy again
um i think hopefully
it should be fixed now sorry for the uh
the rough intro there but i think
it's better hopefully it's looking like
it might be better
[Music]
um
okay it is wonderful
sometimes the tech can be tough to uh
get going here
but we're ready so the first game i want
to go over is a game from today
that uh didn't impact the leaders too
much it's between
uh well actually it did impact the
leaders because alex grisham
uh joined the leader uh with this win
over bogdan daniel dayak um
who was a last minute addition to the
real mania tournament
of course because richard unfortunately
had to drop out last minute
uh so danica's been having a really
interesting event thus far
uh and the interest continues with this
game so
the the story i want to try to tell with
this game uh the lesson to take away
i think is one about avoiding risk
so of course you know dayuk is a
phenomenal world-class player at the
young age of 19.
looking to be a very bright talent for
romania going into the future
but i think in this game he may have
been playing
so risk-averse that he ended up taking
some risks
uh and losing to grishok and this is a
common mistake that i see
when uh players or perhaps a little bit
intimidated
by their opponent myself included have
uh i have fallen into this trap
personally
uh and so i want to take a look at what
that looks like here so
grocery played a relatively tame opening
starting with knight f3
cd5 d4 net f6
c4 e6 and knight c3
so just a normal queen's gambit declined
uh with the the knight development now
dayak
plays a very concrete opening variation
in the form of
c5 so the semitrash in the qgd
of course not related to the other
openings
named after tarash so what do i mean
when i say it's a very concrete line
well
a lot of times in openings with d4d5
black's key break to find a quality is
with this pawn push to c5 otherwise
in lines like the semi-slot you're going
to see that white has
just a little bit of a space advantage
white is applying pressure to black's
center
where black is taking a more defensive
approach just trying to control the
center
more passively also of course white can
claim some kind of edge because
this dark square bishop is able to
develop outside the pawn chain
while this one as of yet is not and
you'll see in openings like this much
later on
black will occasionally try to push
through a c5 to free up
the bishop and free up the position in
general with
the semitrash dayak is immediately
trying to break in the center and find
some sort of equality straight out of
the opening
now the downside to playing so
immediately is that
white of course has one more piece
developed than black
and for that reason white is able to get
a structural advantage
right away and grishik does go for this
with c takes d5
we see c takes d4 queen takes d4
and e takes d5 and this is a position
reached numerous numerous times
um so now rather than black playing with
a spatial disadvantage black is
accepting an isolated queen pawn the
isilani
and this is going to come with its own
set of advantages and
problems basically if black
can trade this pawn for one of white's
pawns or effectively
activate his pieces around the isolated
pawn
taking advantage of its central space
then black will have
in fact found true equality however if
white manages to put
meaningful pressure against the d5 pawn
uh
and black is not able to activate around
it then white is going to
be left with a little bit of an edge
here
now a common move in this position is
actually pawn to e4
but i think this is simplifying a bit
too much black is able to develop now
with knight c6
we see bishop b5 to pin the knight but
after d takes e4
queen takes d8 king takes d8 knight g5
the entry continues a little bit with
bishop to e6
but with the d5 pawn uh being gone
this is very very little for white in
this position and historically
you know something like 80 of the games
have been just a dead draw
from here so grishik instead chooses to
leave some pieces on the board and plays
bishop g5 leaving the queens on the
board
leaving black with this structural
deficit for just a little bit longer
we see bishop b7 by derek so far so good
e3 castle's king side
bishop e2 notably here white chooses
not to bring the bishop out to d3 which
is also a fine move
i think in this case because white is
looking to apply more pressure down the
d
file right away so we get knight c6
by black queen d3 by white
h6 by diak forcing white to make a
decision with this bishop now
of course one option is to capture on f6
trying to weaken black's control over d5
uh of course though this wouldn't uh
immediately be the greatest idea in the
world because
while you do get this d5 pawn this
bishop is going to be very very active
and don't forget that black is generally
not too unhappy
with trading this d5 pawn for another
pawn like the one on b2
um and of course giving up the bishop
pair never something
to to be done lightly so bishop h4
instead
uh day it comes out now with bishop e6
we get castles
and queen b6 so we are nearing sort of
the end
of the opening phase white has finally
gotten castled black has connected the
rooks
and uh activated uh and so far
successfully defended the pawn on d5
and now after a3 we see white managing
defend b2
through sort of tactical means of course
this is a very very common
idea for white and in fact black with a6
to defend against a queen taking on b2
or b7
so what's the trick well of course here
i
think there's actually two options for
white
number one of course with fb1 in this
case i think it actually traps the queen
and maybe a slightly more common trick
is actually involved with
uh knight b4 being able to trap the
queen although here this
looks a little bit complicated but still
winning a piece with uh
you know tactics to follow of course the
point of a3 now
is that the b4 square is defended so
that
the queen cannot retreat a3 also has the
nice bonus of
somehow defending the a3 square by
introducing the rook as a defender so
the queen cannot escape this way either
whereas here of course
under similar circumstances queen a3 or
queen b4 would both be playable
so a3 defending the pawn on b2 we see
rook fd8 now
just controlling this pawn on d5 and
rook fd1
so we are now exiting the opening stage
and black has to find some way um
to activate around the pawn uh continue
activating continue
putting on pressure or to just simply
resolve the struggle around the isolated
pawn
entirely so i'm curious what you guys in
the chat would be able to come up with
uh for black in this position because
from here on out
uh so far dak has made no really
discernible mistakes
just so far playing good opening chess
getting all the pieces in the game
and not really wasting any time doing so
but now
i think is where deoc uh starts to to
adopt this more risk-averse style
and when you play to avoid all risk
you know sometimes you you start making
tiny concessions and
over time those tiny concessions uh may
start to add
up so we need some way to continue here
with the black pieces
chespanzo says looks like they've used a
lot of time already
and well yeah if if you've got alex
bishop with the
uh you know in in the game you're going
to see a lot of time being used but
somehow yes it is only move 14
and grishok is down to 34 minutes dayok
as well
down to 48 uh 48 minutes so they were
thinking for the past couple turns if
i'm not mistaken uh grishak thinking
from very very early on
and then day out really using a lot of
his time on h6
bishop e6 and queen v6 sort of catching
up
with grishik on the time pressure
so matt wilson just wants to play rook a
to
c8 and yeah moves like this are
perfectly fine
perfectly perfectly fine
but is there any way we can sort of
solve black's problems
entirely
so rookie c8 is uh one suggestion
but we need perhaps some concrete ideas
here
and the the thing to remember with this
position is that
uh while the isilani is definitely a
double-edged
uh sword you can rely on it as a
static weakness so of course borrowing
some terminology here
from chess authors but as a static
weakness
in the long run this pawn is going to be
a weakness something that that can be
attacked meanwhile
white's position really doesn't have any
such weaknesses
to speak for so black is going to have
to make use
of the space advantage that this pawn
gives him
to find activity create threats somehow
or
leverage that advantage in space and
activity to
fix the weakness so njf
is saying g5 i think g5 is a little bit
much it's giving yourself more
weaknesses
and we're looking to solve our own
weaknesses so
julian williams in the chat um said d4
and then gave up on it
but i do think d4 is actually a really
great idea here
for black i think d4 would be a way
for black to try to solve all of the
problems
right away now why didn't black play d4
well because it looks a little bit risky
you have to rely on your calculation
here
and you do have to calculate quite a bit
before you play the move d4 but let's go
through some of the lines here so what
happens
if white were to capture on d4 we see
knight takes d4 e takes d4
rook a to c8 let's say rook d2
and now uh how can black fully equalize
uh in this position uh there's actually
a really really clever idea
i've given you a bit of a hint by
playing this mover to c8 for you
but uh black is actually able to
fully equalize without any further
controversy
and the chat room has also come up with
the move knight e4 which is actually the
move
that dayok plays in the game so you're
not doing too badly
that's the 2600 plus level chess move
94.
but black actually has a very clever
idea here to
resolve the tension
okay the chat suggesting bishop c4 but
even better than bishop c4 is rook c4
uh attacking this pawn on d4 yet again
uh
making use of the slateral pin
of the bishop on h4 and
uh white simply has no good response to
this move if you pla
if you try d5 uh this pawn is hanging
you can't or this bishop's hanging you
can't take because of the pin
and if you try to trade first and then
play d5
uh what's going on here chat room what's
going on here
sorry i have uh
too many things
so yes the surprising move rook d4 now
makes use of this bishop being drawn out
to f6 and now
uh white black is actually able to
recapture
this pawn i believe just straight up
right
this rook is defended twice attacked
twice and there's somehow this very
strange configuration
of black pieces it looks very sort of
geometrically pleasing but it gets
the job done um and so
these are the type of complicate
complications that i think dayak was
hoping to avoid because
it's a very risky thing to do you
miscalculate one thing in these
sorts of lines and you might just find
yourself down a pawn
so dayak sort of kicks the can down the
road in this position plays this other
move
knight e4 d4 would have been sort of an
incredible way
to solve all the problems you can't
really blame dayak for uh for
missing all of these calculations i mean
obviously
i have the line with the help of an
engine but
it goes to show sort of the error in
thinking that might be going on here
if you calculate this line and you see
this line uh it's very easy to still not
go with it because it's sort of long
it's complicated
and you're playing alex grishok so you
might think you know if i calculated
one little thing wrong then this line is
is not going to go well for me so
instead chooses a simpler move knight e4
but of course
by playing knight e4 you have not yet
solved your problem
and you do have to uh you know continue
playing with accuracy
to avoid just going down this pawn on d5
so knight e4 of course uh resolves the
tension between these bishops
grisham opts to simply capture on e7
and we get knight takes e7 uh back
grishik now just keeps up the pressure
with the move knight to d4
of course this pawn's defended enough
times and if we take here
once again black is happy to take back
on the b2 square getting rid of this
weakness
um in fact maybe maybe you could even
uh take here first and now i'm thinking
with my own brain
uh because the engine causes the stream
to lag but
uh the reason to do this would be to be
attacking this a pawn as well so
black finding some dynamic equality here
uh if white got the bright idea to take
on e4
so instead we see uh grishak going for
knight d4
instead now uh dak chooses to resolve
the tension between these knights
not letting grishak have a second shot
at taking on e4
c knight takes c3 and grisham simply
plays queen takes c3 keeping this c pawn
off of that off of the open c file and
keeping it from becoming a more
permanent weakness
right to c8 now is played in the game
and we get queen d2
but this problem of the pawn on d5 seems
to be persisting in this position
so sort of this nagging weakness uh
for black and while you know it's not
really enough to lose the chess game
just yet
you sort of just psychologically want
this problem
to be gone you want some way to solve
this problem and so diet continues
trying to play to solve all the problems
with knight f5
grishak again continues simply with
bishop f3
and now we see rook c4 and
at this moment by uh not resolving the
problems
earlier with d4 by going for a simpler
line
diac is actually perhaps going for a
worse way to solve the problem of the d
pawn
with this maneuver knight f5 rook to c4
uh what do i mean by that well of course
here white can actually take this pawn
on d5 by playing knight f5 and bishop
takes d5
uh what was dayak's point well the point
is this rook is opposite the queen
and this bishop is pinned and difficult
to
unpin but of course this variation
is coming with some risk if you don't
play accurately
you have now sacrificed your pawn and
are not
really cleanly getting it back just yet
so that's why uh i think it's important
to talk about this idea of d4
way back on move 14 right this was the
cleanest way
to yes sacrifice the pawn temporarily
but then if you
calculate correctly you can see the
tactics
needed to get the pawn back
and by not playing it here by kicking
the can down the road
and taking the risk with knight f5 and
rook c4
instead dayak actually puts himself in a
position
where it can be very very difficult to
fully equalize we see knight takes f5
bishop takes f5 bishop takes d5 and
bishop e6
is now dayak's idea so of course this
puts white in an awkward spot this
bishop is attacked twice by a rook and a
bishop
and not really adequately defended by
white's pieces
the only move of course is e4
to defend this bishop and now once again
i
don't really like the move that uh dayak
chooses here
um so you know it's
so close you can almost kind of feel it
with the black pieces here
you have very very nearly reached a
quality you just have to find
some way to use the tactical advantages
involving this pin
involving this loose bishop you have to
find some way to use those
to get your pawn back but day i
unfortunately could not quite
find the correct way to follow through
with so little time
left on the clock
great wolf says seems black is trading a
lot isn't the side with the isolated
pawn trying to keep pieces on
for attacking potential so that's
kind of the the more ambitious way to
play and if you see
players with the white pieces going for
an islani
very often that follows with some kind
of attack either in the center on the
kings side
um players with the black pieces
especially at a super high level
a lot of times they are content with
finding
some way to trade off some pieces and
finding
a way to uh get rid of their isolated
pawn you know trade it off for another
pawn
and find some some sort of a quality
right
so that's why we see dayak perhaps not
keeping all the pieces on the board
so black to move here chats what do you
think the path to equality
should be
black to move in this position
and not many suggestions from the chat
so far this one seems to be tough
so keep in mind i think the only way to
fully equalize here
is if we do regain our pawns somehow if
you get any
kind of position where uh white is just
going to keep an extra pawn
you're not going to be fully equal
and yet now my chat's catching up uh
so chess bonzo says bishop takes d5
question mark
i think we can win the pawn back and
that is
the pivotal question uh in this position
i think
dayak was thinking along the lines of
chess bonzo
um and perhaps had a little bit more of
a concrete idea whether or not he could
win the pawn back
when he chose the move bishop takes d5
unfortunately though
you do have to be very very accurate in
order to
keep white from maintaining an extra
pawn after bishop takes d5 and the line
that dayak chose
actually wasn't quite good enough so the
simplest idea here i think is to go
ahead and play rook takes e4
capturing the pawn back like this white
of course
really has no option but to take the
rook sacrifice the queen
and go for this end game with uh two
rooks versus
the queen uh fortunately though for
black here it's going to be really
really difficult
to kind of press at all in this position
um
with the white pieces in my opinion uh
why is that well i think
you can't really make too many concrete
threats
uh black is going to play g6 i'm getting
rid of any back rank made ideas
you can try doubling up i'm gonna play
just king g7 getting to the back row
isn't going to do you much good
because you're immediately going to be
uh sacrificing your own pawns here
on uh on on the queen side
uh you know and moves like this really
you're playing to lose here with white
more than you're playing to win
even ideas like this are never checkmate
the king can simply run out and there's
not enough pieces on the board
for white to go for some kind of attack
oh not to mention i'm hanging back rank
mate don't hang
rank mate in your games everybody um
so i i think rick takes e4 is honestly
the simplest you
get some end game that i think is
entirely drawn
um in the game though we do see bishop
takes d5
e takes d5 and now unfortunately
dioc did not find the precise move to
win
the pawn back so believe it or not i
think
there is really only one tactical idea
that is going to be good enough for
black here to maintain full equality
so some guy with a bunch of numbers for
his name in the chat says no weakness
for white
and rooks are better than the queen so
in this case
i think that's uh you know while you
don't have a weakness like a double pawn
or anything
black is able to uh maintain equality
just because the queen is going to be
able to very easily
apply pressure to these queen sight
pawns and
the white rooks are never going to be
able to invade without leaving these
pawns
behind so white has quote unquote no
weaknesses
black also has no weaknesses and uh are
the rooks better than the queen
you know artificially maybe but in
practice in this end game
there's really nothing to play for there
if white has a dark square bishop then
it'd be dangerous i might agree with
that i might agree with that
gabriel harris says rook d6 and slowly
gang up on the pawn so what's the
problem
with the slower approach in this case
what if i play a move like rook d6
well as white here you do have
sort of a nice way to continue to press
for an advantage let's say i play a move
like h3 first and the reason i'm going
to play a move
like h3 here is because i'm thinking
about the position
that comes after what happens after
you win your pawn back is what i'm
interested in here with the white pieces
and what happens after is i want to be
using my major pieces
to invade the seventh rank and pick up
your other pawns
while you're busy capturing my pawn uh
and that is the reason why white is
going to maintain some advantage here if
you play slowly
yes you might be able to win the pawn
back but you're going to be losing
something uh in return for it i'm not
sure rick h3 is the
you know the the most accurate by the
way let's start with something like rook
c1 first even
so let's say rook c1 what are you going
to play with black here
to uh to to get your pawn back are you
going to play rook c5
are you going to play rook c5 everybody
somebody say yes let's look at rook c5
why don't we
um so what's the problem with playing
like
this well first and foremost i actually
don't know if you're even getting your
pawn back
i can simply take play queen d4 and
you have attacked the d-pawn as much as
you possibly
can and i have defended it uh just as
many times
and so you don't get the pawn back here
so playing slowly not going to be good
enough
by the way this other move h3 i think is
is likely also going to be
edge for uh for white in this case for
example to move queen e3
and if you take here um well actually
i'm i'm making a threat so you can't
even take there
and i'm going to be able to to build up
over here with moves like b4 and again
moves like rook c1 to follow
um so in the game deoc plays this move
queen b5 but again
this turns out to be slightly too slow
in this position
so we need something more uh more fast
faster some would say with the black
pieces
so what can we do how can we get there
faster
b4 after rook d6 is another fine move
just
it's not so so easy to get this pawn
back
rook d4 would be a great move if it
didn't hang a rook
but it does hang a brook so it's not
such a good move
so alberto has the correct first move
but uh what's the idea and rithwick has
the full idea here we need
to attack this pawn as quickly as
possible and we actually have a very
clever idea
of using a tactical resource to
uh gain back this pawn and this is what
tactics look like
sort of uh at the very high level uh
yeah black has
a ton of different ways to go after this
pawn and we see queen b5 in the game is
one of those ways
but you use your other resources in the
position
not necessarily like as your only threat
but use them as a means to an end so in
this case
we need to attack this pawn somehow so
right now we're threatening rook c5
white's only try
to stop rook c5 is going to be b4 if you
play rook c1
i'll take and uh
well hold on if you play rook c1 i'll
take d5 that's
that's the tactic there if you take my
queen i'll take back
if you take one rook i'll take the other
and you get checkmated
um so
rook c1 not going to be good enough so
how else can we stop rook c5 well you
have to play b4
and now black has this tactical idea to
reroute this rook somewhere a lot better
and that's rook h4
threatening checkmate um h3 or g3
and now rook h5 and thus black is
successfully
regaining the pawn a lot of work just to
take back this weak pawn on d5
instead of course
crusoe is coming from another youtuber
gotham chess's
um recap i think uh i think this game
might have
i don't think this one made it to
agunmatter's channel just yet so uh
hopefully i'm coming in before
um the the really popular guys although
i guess gotham tresses may be more
popular now
unclear but anyways queen b5
not going to get it done queen d6 was
the accurate way
to get this rook into position and
regain this pawn
so queen b5 chosen instead and now
we need some way to press for an
advantage as white
grisha being the monster that he is has
eight and a half minutes on the clock
and spends seven of it to find the move
h3
only alexander grishok would spend seven
of his eight minutes on the move
h3 and of course i i think h3 is
the best move and what does this move do
well you saw in all of those previous
positions
um that well the previous position
specifically number one
this tactical resource uh threatening h2
number two the other tactical resource
involved this back rank mate
so grishik says all right uh i'll spend
my seven minutes i'll stop
the back rank mate and uh you know now
it's my opponent's turn
so now the problem for black is that
this queen
is also not blockading this pawn so if
you go after it with rook c5
we're simply going to push to d6 now if
you go after this guy again
uh white is simply going to play b4
and the problem now is that if you
attack this pawn again either with
uh queen b6 or i think even with queen
e5
we're going to play this move d7 and now
the problem is if you continue with rook
c7
we get a similar end game to the one
that we were looking at with the two
rooks
but very significantly our rooks have
invaded
in this position so this really wasn't
an option with the bishops on the board
the bishop on e6
really controlled a lot of the squares
kept the rooks out forever
but now of course this is going to be a
pretty significant advantage
for white your rooks are simply too
active
and you are going to be taking black's
pawns
so that's why the simple approach
doesn't work with just capturing
so we see deoc using the rook instead to
blockade
but now we've already seen that rook d6
initially
was a little bit too slow we get b4 by
white here stopping rook c5 and now
black has simply no comfortable way
to attack this pawn he tries the slow
approach once
once again with rook c7 and now we know
that black is going to play rook d7 on
the next move
uh trying to regain the pawn
so as grishik now we know black's plan
how can we keep up the pressure how can
we can we leverage this extra pawn
into something more
sean says would black try to win a3 and
b4 there so in that queen versus true
rex ending
uh the problem is once your f and g
pawns are gone
uh white is going to be uh taking pawns
and also threatening checkmate right the
two rooks are able to uh
threaten some pretty nasty things
against the black king so
the queen strays too far uh with
something like queen a4 in those kinds
of positions
um you're definitely running
a bit too much of a risk there
steph says queen e3
blaze says queen d3 with mating motifs
so queen d3 i don't think
is going to be good enough although
superficially that move looks kind of
interesting um i'm not sure
you're actually ever going to get
checkmate of course it's offering a
queen trade
but uh queen e3 seems like an
interesting idea what else can you guys
come up with
what else do you guys have so far you
guys haven't come up with grishard's
idea which is fair grace looks
pretty good at chess
all right rom has the wrong notation but
i think the right idea
so uh grishok was looking to make use
of this back rank for black and found
this idea
of queen to f4 in the game so why is
this the best option well for one
it sort of narrows the range of moves
you have to look at
black strike is attacked there's really
only one move here and that's to defend
the rook with rook c to d7
and number two it effectively acts as a
pin
so now grishok uh is able to play this
move queen b8 check in response to any
time
this rook is going to move and with
queen v8 check grishok is looking to
pick up this pawn
on a7 now these other moves i think
white is probably going to be slightly
better after
almost anything but here i think uh
you're maybe letting get
black get away with a little bit too
much uh just off hand i think this move
queen to e8
looks like a simple enough uh try
for black in this position now why is
this a simple enough try well we're
going to bring this queen to d8
and now we can essentially pick up this
pawn at our leisure for example queen d4
makes a threat so i'll take my time to
resolve the threat
here here here and i think i can even
get away with taking
on d5 so this queen d3 move may be a
little bit slow
probably white's going to be a little
bit better in some of the lines
but uh i think the queen is actually
better placed on the back rank
than on b5 queen e3 with a similar idea
of attacking this pawn on a7
in this case i i think white is also
going to be better just for the same
reasons
in fact this idea is maybe a little bit
simpler than what's played in the game
but we'll see in the game grishik
actually manages to get this rook to c1
so you can compare this where we have
the queen in the seven and the rook on
a1
with the position found in the game
uh with the queen on a7 and the rook on
c1 so grisham basically just finding the
most accurate way
to bring the pieces in either way still
winning the pawn
so queen f4 grishak is one to be
accurate
and uh gets the pieces a little bit
further into the game
now of course grishik has a minute 20 on
the clock deck has a minute 28
and we're gonna see a crazy time
scramble so i'm going to blast through
the next few moves here
grishik of course has at this point won
the middle game battle
by getting this extra pawn now is the
position winning
that's a different question entirely and
the rest of this game is going to be
a little bit of a clown fiesta as they
say
in the severe time pressure but the
really really interesting part to me
was this early middle game where dayak
missed this chance to play d4
uh fully equalizing and then not wanting
to go into the queen versus two rooks
ending
that was fully drawn uh perhaps
fearing uh you know any slight risk
fearing that he would get something
wrong and grisham would take advantage
and by not taking any risks of course he
took the greatest risk of all
and uh ends up with a much worse
position here
uh but we still got a lot of chess game
left we see g6 queen c3
queen f4 now rookie one for white
what is this move doing well it takes
the rook off of a square where it's
attacked
never a bad idea in time pressure uh
rook d2 queen e3
richard's just trying to keep control
over all
of the pawns and keep the king safe uh
we
queen back to d6 queen f3 and at this
point
it it sort of doesn't matter too much
what grishook
uh does he's he's still going to be up
upon which is what's making his position
perhaps slightly easier to play than
deox deck is just searching
for threats ways to make grishard try
and trip
up but you know pawn is a pawn
as they say uh grisham
how much time he's down to 39 seconds
here um
so queen c7 now queen f6 by white is
sort of poking and prodding
uh rook d6 makes the queen move again
grisham of course would be happy with an
end game here
although how winning is this oh well
it's it's super winning because
this is a fork okay so uh rook d7
instead
queen e5 rook d or queen d8
now g3 grisha perhaps making some light
squared weaknesses in an effort to get
the king off the back rank
uh b6 now marks time we get a4
rook d4 rook e4
check king h2 queen a8
and a little bit of scariness but b5
defends everything
rook f1 queen d4
and somehow grishik manages to not make
any mistakes
um or too many mistakes uh without with
so little time on the clock
now we see g4 perhaps giving a little
bit too much access to this king
but grishik does navigate the
complications here
um queen v8 and here actually
lee chess and stockfish claim to find
equality
through the move queen d5 keeping
pressure here
and then if you follow up with your
threat playing something like queen
takes b6
i think the idea is simply yeah rook d1
and some sort of perpetual check here
so you know what i mean it's time
pressure g4
gives a little bit too much access so
black has some crazy tactical ideas
with so little time on the clock it
would be very impressive if either
player
saw these things but still worth noting
that g4
a little bit of a mistake you shouldn't
weaken your king like that
especially with so little time uh but
in the game we don't see this idea for
uh black black did not come up with
queen d5 instead choosing just to
capture the pawn
but now after queen v6 white again has
everything under
control if you try this queen d5 idea
again um
it's just not as strong here and i can
easily tell you the reason
because i know what i'm talking about
queen f6
is the reason and now if you play rook
a1 i take it
uh and if you don't play rook a1 i might
check me chu so
scary stuff so instead we get rook f4
and this idea but now uh black is
is just uh looking a little bit busted
here
um king h7 is perhaps the final mistake
now queen f8
and there's no good way to defend this
f7 pawn uh we saw rook f4 in the game
but these queen endings are pretty much
always lost
one past pawn tends to be enough
especially if you don't have access to
the enemy king
and black really can't even make any
threats here so we see h5
queen c6 and the queen unable to stay on
this diagonal
attacking g4 uh black simply resides
in this position um and that is
the grishak bogdan game uh bogdan daniel
dayak i don't know what he goes by i'm
sorry i'm bad does he go by daniel does
he go by dayok
dax's last name and somebody goes by
that's tough i'll call him deoc
so grishook with the amazing win
and again the lesson i think you should
take away from this game is that
you need to trust your calculation no
matter who you're playing against
if you can calculate a way to solve your
problems
uh you you sort of have to believe
yourself at some point and go for it
because if you keep kicking the can down
the road keep trying to be risk-averse
uh in the end you're gonna be making
concessions and those concessions are
going to start to add up
okay so let us move along now i want to
talk about
one more game and that is this one
between fabiona carowana
and constantine lupulescu
so constantine of course is the romanian
number one player
uh getting his shot at the regular top
ten
here in romania and my chat room is
telling me it's just bogdan i'll just
call him bogdan then
sounds good to me daniel is his second
first name
which is a little bit of an oxymoron um
but okay so let's take a look at this
game so fabi played e4
we end up in a french and this is
i don't think this is new territory for
lucolescu
um i was watching the fabi interview he
gave after this game
and he was talking about uh how in his
previous tournament with leski had only
played like
the sicilian or something but fabi was
really ready for anything
so we get the classical french with
knight f6 none of this bishop b4
garbage so knight f6 and fabi plays one
of the main lines with bishop g5
we see take on e4 take on e4 knight bd7
uh knight f3 super normal stuff so far
and fabi goes for this simpler line with
bishop takes f6
rather than knight takes f6
and bishop back to h4 or e3 or something
like that just trading off the bishop
uh now we see bishop d3 here knight e4
bishop b4
and black pushes out to c5 um
once again we see the c5 move coming
into play challenging white's
uh spatial advantage in this case though
black's not ending up with an iqp
queen e2 is normal and now after c3
cd4 knight d4 bishop b7 we see the point
of white's play
with queen e2 the point is that white
was looking
to castle queenside this was fabi's
big idea here unfortunately it wasn't
really enough to
surprise constantine in this position
but
uh it surprised me so you know there
there you go fabi
you may have not surprised your opponent
with this queenside castles prep
but you did surprise me of course a move
like king side castles
would look a little bit more normal here
but it's really
not going to be too challenging to
black's position
i would say so queensland castles by
fabi interesting stuff
and i think the idea here more so than
uh being able to
you know do the classical opposite side
castling games where you push
all the pawns and play for checkmate
bobby has one
very specific idea here but sometimes
one idea is really all you need
and uh fabi said as much sort of in his
interview he really has only one idea in
the position
but it turns out to be a pretty good
idea it's a pretty testing idea
and uh lupulescu was unable to find the
way
to navigate the complications um one two
three four four four
rbi says take the pawn lol and you've
fallen
for uh fabi's devious trap so of course
now queen v5 check
is going to be causing you a little bit
uh you know a few problems here if you
play bishop d7
um i think we're simply going to take
this pawn here on
b7 with the queen yeah i don't see why
not
play something like rook c8 we're
running into bishop c6
and it's getting very very awkward very
very quickly for the player with the
black pieces
this is a pin um this bishop is attacked
twice if you take here i take here if
you take here i take here
and it's not looking so good not looking
so good so rook d8
might be a better try but then knight c6
and you have very similar problems
so queen a2 not going to be the best
idea you have to play like king f8 here
and uh you know what white should pretty
significantly
be better in this position uh
king is just weak so queen side castles
and black goes ahead and casts king's
side before taking on a2
what about king of fate instead okay if
we can look at this a little bit more
thoroughly king f8 and
again not gonna turn on the engine
because it's uh
freezes my stream so apologies if i make
any mistakes here
but i think we may be able to capture on
b7
although that does look does look
slightly risky
maybe this move knight c6 is already
going to be
challenging again maybe not though take
take this bishop a6
um yeah let's go with bishop takes b7
and i lied i'm going to cheat no this
move's awful
i thought i had this here nah it just
doesn't work
just doesn't work this is not a double
attack why would
you ever think it's a double attack so
what's the refutation here what do we do
uh ah simply knight b3 and this queen is
like trapped or something
um yeah it looks looks tough for black
king c2 rook a1
is a simple enough idea you can't play
queen a6 i take it
play something like our v8 i think i
still just go queen c2
king c2 you save your piece i think this
is
simple enough and black is just uh
never really getting off the ground here
tough to bring the rook into the game
tough to bring the bishop
into the game and everything looks quite
sad
um so not queen a2 but kingside castles
and now king b1 by fabi
and sort of the the opening um
trials and tribulations here so
uh lupulescu then thinks for a while and
plays rook d8 which seems like a fine
move
and fabi goes about playing his one idea
so who in the chat
knows what fabi's one idea was
who knows the idea here
what's bobby's point in this position
any 1400 that plays a lot of online
blitz will see this idea immediately
queen f3 your knight takes e6 way too
classy
way too classy you put the queen in
front of the bishop
and then you checkmate black easy stuff
guys
easy stuff it works in my blitz games
why wouldn't it work here
1400s aren't playing knight takes e6
okay that's way too classy guys way too
classy
everybody knows you put the queen in
front of the bishop you play queen h7
that's checkmate um
so of course i'm only kind of joking
here
um this idea is a bit classier
uh and it does work a lot better when
there's no knight on
f6 and that's fobby's point here the uh
knight from the king's side is missing
it's an important defender and when that
defender is gone
black is forced to make some concessions
uh
around the king's side to deal with this
threat so what concession is that well
black has to play this move g6
which might not seem like a lot but now
fabi continues his idea
how do we continue here
yeah mike's seen that one before
i think we've all seen this one before
so blaze says f slash g slash h4
choose one and i guess that's the idea
which one
which one and yeah great wolf has the
right idea we want to check mate black
this pawn's in the way let's get it out
of the way h4
h5 h takes g is fobby's point and while
this
is sort of a caveman-esque it is
you know posing some questions to black
and that's what uh
playing with the white pieces at the top
level is all about you give your
opponent a problem
if they solve it they get to maybe uh
equalize
they don't solve it then you get to win
the game and that's what uh
fobby's opening prep is is all about of
course there are no forced wins
in chest from the get-go if your
opponent plays well
they're going to be able to equalize so
the best you can do is come up with
interesting problems
and uh you know ask your opponent how
they're going to solve them
and in this case unfortunately for
lupulescu he did not
find the correct way to solve the
problems
and watching the interview that fabi
gave after it's really tough to blame
them
for not finding the best way to solve
the problems here so
as black i i'm not even going to ask the
chat room
to try and find this one i just want to
show you guys some of what fabio was
calculating
um this is what he had to say in the
interview in fact the best move for
black
is this move e5 and fabio was like yeah
i was really expecting him to
find this move e5 i think what he was
worried about is
i was going to play h5 then after e
takes d4
of course the bishop is hanging but
we're not going to take the bishop
that's way too simple
h takes g6 now i'm threatening queen e7
i'm threatening g takes f in queen h7
queen g6 stuff
with with checkmate uh and black really
only has one move to solve it which is
queen g5
so uh you know i think he was expecting
queen g5
and i wasn't really sure what i was
going to go for here but i think the
safe move is
f4 uh when black now has to play queen
takes g6 because if you play queen
f6 of course this is simply losing to
rook takes h6 i believe it was
um among other things so he plays you
know yes play queen takes g6 and you
know i can take on e7 but black has
bishop f5 here
and then what i was calculating is that
maybe i have bishop f5
or queen f5 king a1 and after something
like rook d7 i can go queen h4
and have ideas against the king on the
king's side
uh in here i was thinking you know d
take c3 maybe i have queen takes h6
but oh never mind my calculation was all
wrong because at the end he just tezra
takes d1 and then i have no threats on
the king's side
and that is literally almost verbatim
the interview
that fabi gave so just so you know
um up to this point i think this is the
engine number one line so if you ever
you know are curious about the
calculation strength of fabiano caruana
he's like yeah i expected my opponent to
play the best move and then
play would have probably followed like
this and then he just says like
everything that stockfish says
so that's what it takes to be world
number two i guess
um so perhaps fearing some of these
things that fabi had
correctly calculated out uh lupulescu
did not find this move e5
and according to the engine that's
really the only way black has to
equalize and you you really do have to
find all these crazy defensive ideas
swinging the queen over to g5 and then
white just has no way to break through
apparently um that's coming from fabi uh
instead lupulescu said this bishop's a
really good attacker i'm gonna trade it
off
and chose bishop a4 um according to the
computer the
next best thing was to play h5 and this
makes some sense
but i also understand why lubellescu
didn't want to go for it it's sort of
the natural response to h4 you just want
to stop
stop white from playing h5 entirely but
of course here
the natural way to continue with white
is simply play g4 you know continue the
caveman attack
and turns out g4 does keep up a little
bit of pressure here
for white and black can't really fully
equalize it's
it's tough to deal with this idea of h5
coming
on the next turn um so bishop a4 it is
instead for lupulescu but now fabi finds
the only path
towards an advantage we take on a4 take
on a4
and play h5 continuing to break down the
light squares
black now has to play g5 and
unfortunately with this move
what black has made enough concessions
on the king's side
enough weaknesses on the king's side
that fabi can get away with
snagging this extra pawn here on b7
now black unfortunately makes a second
mistake with bishop
c5 by putting this bishop here fabi is
actually able to force a queen trade
and more so than the queen trade is able
to force his opponent into a passive
position
uh in the end game and he does so with
this move queen c6
and this is why bishop c5 was worse than
bishop f6
because now there is no way to avoid the
trade of queens why do i say that
well if you go queen a5 i go knight b3
and if you go queen c4 then knight b3 i
think again
uh making use of this pin is good and
fabi in his interview again
gave like a seven move variation
explaining why it works
but you know attack the pin piece come
on fabi it's not it's not that hard
um so of course now black has to take
and
why is bishop f6 better well here you
would have the smooth queen a5
and this knight b3 idea wouldn't quite
be so strong your queen can
slide across and the bishop is not
attacked
um of course white's still better there
because of the extra pawn but after this
the queen trait is forced and now fabi
simply invades with rook d7
black for the moment has the pawn back
but is just way
too passive to survive this f6
was um lupulsku's choice and this one
isn't going to get the job done
we see 98 now hits the pawn on e6
uh bishop e6 fabi doesn't even take the
pawn instead going knight f7
ready to snag the pawn on h6 rook f8 we
see the check
and white plays king c2 here which is
the meanest idea
and lupulescu simply resigns why does
black resign here
well good luck finding a legal move it's
not going to be so easy
um honestly like find a move you can't
play rook d8 you get forked
um you can't move the king legally if
you play something like rook c8
you are gonna run into stuff like uh
i think the simplest is just the
the check maybe even like rook f7 is
easy enough just picking up all the
pawns all the pawns are just gonna fall
um and so lupulesco had seen enough and
resigned
the game it's a really impressive game
by fabi i wanted to show it off here
and showing that sometimes one idea is
enough
you have to find some way to pose a
problem to your opponent
and uh and in this case one problem was
enough it was a very difficult problem
to solve
and lubellescu did not manage to solve
it so good game for fobby
of course in this previous round that
happened this morning uh
us time uh wesley so actually managed to
defeat fabi
with help from god according to wesley
uh don't know if he could have done it
without jesus wesley thinks he couldn't
but uh thankfully for big wes
jesus did get him there and uh took out
fabi so fabi
back on plus zero with an even score
after today's round
but still an impressive game nonetheless
and we are actually i think running out
of time here
so let me switch back to my full screen
if i can uh no more intro
just my face um thank you all so much
for watching this road 2000
uh from the comfort of my home to yours
i hope uh coming up next is going to be
a
great stream from var okobian he's going
to be teaching another class it's great
to have var back
here on the channel it's been some time
so be sure to check that out he's not
going to be here for too much longer so
catch these lectures while you can
as always though my name is caleb denby
i want to thank you so much for watching
and i will see you next time goodbye
you